el momento de votar los aplausos que
recibió de sugar sonaron a
aprobación por parte de su propio
partido por lo demás no hubo sorpresas
ya que su ga fue elegido el primer
ministro de japón número 99 por una
mayoría abrumadora con el principal
líder de la oposición muy por detrás
este hombre de 71 años es el primer
nuevo mandatario de japón en casi 8 años
aunque pocos esperan algo más que un
simple cambio de cara no creo que las
cosas sean mucho peores ni mucho mejor
es poco cambiará bajo un laico espero
que el nuevo gobierno supere la crisis
de coronavirus y celebren los juegos
olímpicos sin grandes cambios en su
política fuga ganando la carrera por el
liderazgo del partido gobernante con la
promesa de estabilidad y continuidad y
hereda un país en profunda recesión el
pib japón se redujo casi un 8% en el
segundo trimestre en medio de la
pandemia la política monetaria muy
liberal llamada ave no mix no logró
fortalecer la economía en cuanto a la
política exterior se espera que suba
continúa priorizando
la relación de japón con eeuu mientras
tanto temas como una disputa territorial
con rusia están destinados a permanecer
en un punto muerto
de basic o la política exterior básica
de japón se basará en el fortalecimiento
de la alianza de seguridad entre japón y
eeuu japón no tratará de dañar sus
relaciones con china tanto como pueda
pero no se reunirá de equilibrarse con
china le enseñó alguien china con
aproximadamente la mitad del gabinete
compuesto por miembros del precedente y
teniendo al hermano menor de ave como
nuevo ministro de defensa el gobierno de
su hogar es visto en gran medida como
una copia del anterior